la distribución normal es quizás la más
el más importante de los conceptos en
estadística todo lo que hacemos y todo
lo que hacemos en estadística
inferencial es esencialmente basado en
datos que hasta cierto punto están
basados en una distribución normal así
que lo que quiero hacer en este vídeo en
esta hoja de cálculo es que es
esencialmente darles un un entendimiento
profundo de lo que es esta distribución
tanto como sea posible para que por el
resto de tu vida tú sepas qué es la
distribución normal su fórmula cómo se
usa etcétera así que esta hoja de
cálculo así como sabes es descargable en
www.cai.es diagonal downloads y hasta
ahí bueno ahí puedes ver todo lo que se
puede descargar diagonal normal intro
punto xls y ahí se puede descargar de
esto
de cualquier forma así si vas a la
wikipedia puedes encontrar ahí tecleando
la distribución normal
de hecho déjenme poner mi herramienta de
pluma esto es lo que van a encontrar
literalmente yo copie y pegue esta
fórmula de la wikipedia pero bueno esta
sigma de aquí por ejemplo esa es la
desviación estándar de la distribución
vamos a jugar un poquito en esta gráfica
con eso para ver qué significa y digo ya
sabemos lo que significa la desviación
estándar pero esta es la desviación
estándar de esta distribución que es una
función de densidad de probabilidad y te
sugiero que vean de nuevo los vídeos de
funciones de densidad porque es un
poquito difícil saltar de la
distribución vino vía binomial que es
discreta a la normal
por ejemplo en la binomial teníamos
valores discretos es decir por ejemplo
nos fijábamos en el histograma pero en
una probabilidad continua no podemos
decir cuál es la probabilidad de obtener
un 5 necesitamos decir la probabilidad
de estar entre algunos valores digamos
entre 4.5 y 5.5 y ahí tendremos no sé en
algún rango no entonces nuestra
probabilidad
podremos leer en esta no la podemos leer
en la gráfica sino que vamos a calcular
el área bajo la curva esta área así que
para los que ya saben cálculo type de x
es la función de densidad de
probabilidad de una distribución normal
bueno en general no es una distribución
normal pero casi siempre
digamos que queremos calcular la
probabilidad de que mañana lluevan entre
4.5 y 5.5 pulgadas de lluvia entonces
vamos a tener la integral de 4.5 a 5.5
de la función de densidad de
probabilidad
en este caso es la que está acá arriba
de px de x así que ese es el área debajo
de la curva para los que no han visto el
cálculo les sugiero que vean los vídeos
toda la lista de vídeos así que estamos
obteniendo toda el área de 4.5 a 5.5
debajo de esa curva y esto es difícil de
encontrar analíticamente analíticamente
pero no numéricamente porque bueno como
encontramos la integral de esto este
podemos aproximar lo una forma de
aproximar lo es por ejemplo si como lo
hacíamos en general con integral es
verdad usar el área de éste trapezoide y
digamos aquí podemos figurar nos el área
de éste trapezoide verdad pero también
podríamos tomarnos el punto medio de la
base y déjenme déjenme cambiar de color
porque ya se está volviendo esto muy
verde
así que tomamos el punto medio digamos
tomamos esta altura que está dada por la
función y multiplicamos por la base para
obtener el área de este rectángulo que
que puede ser una muy buena aproximación
verdad porque del lado derecho tenemos
un excedente de área
que es la que aparece como que la que le
falta del lado izquierdo así que es lo
que voy a hacer en este vídeo vamos a
aproximar el área debajo de la curva y
dar una buena un buen entendimiento de
lo que es la distribución normal a
partir de una binomial que esencialmente
si uno tiene muchos intentos de un
experimento digamos lo que es
interesante de la distribución normal
digamos si esta es la gráfica es la
gráfica
esto en otras palabras es lo que la
gente le llama el teorema del límite
central que es una de las cosas más
interesantes del universo el teorema del
límite central no lo voy a demostrar
aquí por esencialmente nos dice que si
tenemos algún tipo de fenómeno digamos
tirar monedas
y lanzamos muchas monedas todas ellas
son independientes de cada uno de los
otros intentos entonces si tomamos la
suma de cada una de esas variables y
aproximamos por un número infinito de
ellas tendremos una distribución normal
lo que es interesante a partir de estos
intentos es que bueno realmente nunca
tome que fuera una distribución normal
cada uno de los intentos de la moneda
simplemente podíamos hablar de
interacciones moleculares en algún
compuesto x que interactúa con otro
compuesto y no sé
puede no tener una distribución normal
por lo que pasa es que si tomamos la
suma de una infinidad de este tipo de
interacciones entonces tendremos al
final una distribución normal y eso es
por eso es tan importante esta
distribución aparece en la naturaleza
todo el tiempo y si tomamos puntos de
datos de algún fenómeno muy complejo
la suma seguramente la suma de una
infinidad de este tipo de intentos va a
parecerse muy bien a una distribución
normal ok entonces
de cualquier forma vamos a digerir esto
un poco más déjenme reescribir todo esto
esto es lo que encontrará en la
wikipedia no debe reescrito como a lo
mejor de esta forma uno entre sigma por
la raíz de dos pi y aquí la
exponenciales es tomar a la este
exponente verdad que es menos x menos la
media al cuadrado entre 2 sigma cuadrada
pero sigma es la desviación estándar y
sigma cuadrada es la varianza
así que como ya sabemos todas estas
letras griegas realmente lo que nos está
diciendo es la altura de una función de
distribución ok entonces
digamos que esta distribución es
no sé qué tan lejos viven al norte la
gente de mi casa o qué bueno no fue muy
buen ejemplo digamos la altura la altura
digamos que la media es 5.9 y esto nos
dice que sí que cuál es la probabilidad
por ejemplo cuál es la probabilidad de
que de encontrar a alguien que tiene 5
pulgadas más alto que el promedio sale
entonces aquí pone 15 en la equis y
entonces tendremos una desviación
estándar conocidas que no hacemos la
varianza la media y simplemente
colocamos la el valor que nosotros
queramos encontrar digamos en este caso
5 ahora bien no podemos saber cuál cuál
es la probabilidad de encontrar
exactamente una persona que tiene 5
verdad podríamos dar un rango a lo mejor
entre 4.9 y 5.1 verdad porque es
infinitamente imposible que sea
exactamente 5.9 verdad o cualquier
número
así que así es como usamos esta función
que es muy fuertemente usada les digo
aparece en todo lo que es la estadística
inferencial y espero que te vuelvas y te
pongas o te familiarices con esto espero
que eso ocurra así que déjenme jugar un
poquito con con la intuición de cómo
funciona todo esto si fuéramos a tomar
esto y voy a recurrir a tu memoria si
pudiéramos reescribir esto digamos
que la sigma lo pudiéramos escribir
dentro de la raíz tendríamos 1 entre 2 y
por sigma cuadrada ok casi nunca se
escribe de esta forma pero bueno al
menos sigma cuadrada representa a la
varianza verdad y así de hecho eso se
puede calcular de hecho se calcula antes
que la desviación estándar verdad
y esto x era la menos un medio
simplemente tomamos el resto
y lo escribimos como x menos mu sobre
sigma y todo esto al cuadrado verdad y
este tipo de expresión clarifica mucho
más porque qué es esto x menos no es la
distancia que hay entre cualquier punto
bueno el punto que queremos encontrar
digamos este de aquí x menos no es la
distancia que hay de ese punto a la
media verdad y si dividimos entre sigma
que es la desviación estándar y es esta
medida lo que nos dice es cuántas
desviaciones estándar caben en esa
distancia de hecho esto es lo que
llamamos la acepta estándar de la de la
que hablamos en otro vídeo y si elevamos
al cuadrado pero me faltó multiplicar
por menos un medio verdad pero miren
fíjense si tengo esa la menos un medio
por esto es que al a
y todo esto al menos un medio verdad así
que tomamos el exponente y realmente
estamos tomando este número y dividiendo
entre la raíz cuadrada así que esto
déjenme reescribirlo como 1 entre la
raíz de 2 pi por sigma cuadrada por y
ahora vamos a jugar con con la formulita
de los exponentes verdad esto los los
invito a que me manden un email si si
empiezan a ver de dónde sale todo esto
otra vez creo que está muy bien que
veamos distintas fórmulas por ejemplo
aquí vuelve a aparecer
como en la fórmula de hoy leer no son
son números que están relacionados y que
nos hablan mucho de cómo está hecho el
universo verdad así como la fórmula de
la eep y igual a menos 1 verdad pero
bueno de cualquier forma déjenme
reescribir esto como a a la x menos mu
sobre sigma al cuadrado y todo esto lo
elevó a la menos un medio y que
significa elevar a la menos un medio en
realidad significa tomar raíz
y entre eso verdad así que esto lo
podemos reescribir como
1 sobre la raíz cuadrada
de 2 p por la varianza que sigma
cuadrada por e
a la esencialmente estamos elevando a la
zeta al puntaje z verdad y al cuadrado
todo esto es el puntaje z
y esto al cuadrado y luego todo esto se
ve bastante claro verdad tenemos
2 por la varianza por el acepta cuadrada
y
y sacamos la raíz cuadrada y luego
tomamos el inverso el recíproco verdad
de cualquier forma creo que es bueno e
interesante jugar con las fórmulas de
esa forma cuando veas estas fórmulas por
el resto de tu vida ya vas a saber de
qué estamos hablando no que la
distribución normal pero bueno con esto
dicho vamos a jugar con los parámetros
de la distribución normal en esta hoja
de cálculo y graficado la distribución
puedes cambiar digamos los parámetros de
estos cuadritos en azul así que ahorita
estamos graficando
la distribución normal con media 0 y
desviación estándar 4
digamos entonces la varianza es es 16
así que qué pasa si movemos la media de
0 a 5 web la gráfica se movió hacia la
derecha por cinco unidades verdad estaba
centrada aquí y ahora está centrada en 5
ahora qué pasa si ponemos menos 5 ahora
toda la campana se movió 5 unidades a la
izquierda del centro que pasa si
cambiamos la desviación estándar la
varianza es el promedio de las
distancias cuadradas de la media verdad
ok entonces la desviación estándar es la
raíz cuadrada de eso así que bueno es
digamos más o menos el promedio de las
distancias a la media no no tan así pero
bueno
vamos a cambiarlo vamos a ver qué pasa
cuando cambiamos la desviación estándar
entonces la gráfica se parece cada vez
más a la media verdad si hacemos digamos
la desviación estándar igual a 10 todo
se empieza apachurrar y ahora esta
gráfica por supuesto se extiende
en toda la recta verdad pero bueno
tenemos un número corto de valores en
donde está concentrado la probabilidad
aunque está definida la función en toda
la recta real por ejemplo si tenemos una
desviación estándar de 10 hay una ligera
probabilidad de obtener un 1000 pero es
muy baja hay cierta probabilidad pero es
muy baja ok
por ejemplo la probabilidad de que todos
los átomos de mi cuerpo se arreglen de
alguna forma cuando me siento bueno a lo
mejor tardará mucho la vida del universo
para que eso ocurra pero bueno esto
puede describir que puede pasar
cualquier cosa aunque de forma muy poco
probable así que de lo que he hablado en
esta distribución
puedes figurar te lo en una distribución
normal que no puedes
representar lo que vale la probabilidad
en cada punto verdad sino que tienes que
dar la probabilidad de que esté entre 22
valores digamos si éste es nuestra
distribución y yo quiero saber cuál es
la probabilidad de digamos no sé qué
fenómeno es este pero de obtener un cero
digamos que sea exactamente cero la
probabilidad de cero debería usar menos
el número cero pero justamente el área
debajo del cero no hay área es una línea
así que tenemos que dar una probabilidad
entre dos valores digamos nos entre
menos de ocho lo puedo poner aquí arriba
puedo decir la probabilidad de entre -0
punto
0.05 a 0.005 bueno está redondeado dice
que está cerca al 0 déjenme hacerlo con
otros no menos digamos entre menos uno y
uno
me calculó que era el 7 por ciento ok
y esto lo hizo en un segundo así que
déjenme ver qué es lo que hizo entre uno
y menos uno lo que está haciendo excel
digamos estamos entre menos uno que es
más o menos por aquí y uno por acá
estamos calculando el área debajo de la
curva
el área debajo de la curva para estos
dos valores digamos desde cálculos
sabemos que esa área la podemos
encontrar como la integral desde menos 1
a 1 de esta función la p de x donde la
desviación estándar sigma es 10 y la
media es menos 5 así que estamos
calculando calculando para este ejemplo
la en la integral de la función de
distribución de la normal que es uno
entre sigma que es 10 por la raíz de dos
pi por ea la menos un medio x
x menos menos la media que es menos 5
así que realmente tendríamos 5 positivo
verdad que sería x + 5 sobre la
desviación estándar que es 10
y todo esto al cuadrado verdad
y esto respecto a x esto es lo que nos
está encontrando este 7% o lo que es
equivalente a punto 07 eso es lo que
estamos encontrando desafortunadamente
evaluar esta integral de forma analítica
es muy difícil así que lo vamos a hacer
numéricamente y una forma fácil
relativamente de hacerlo bueno no tan
fácil pero pero bueno hemos de fin se ha
definido una función que que es es una
herramienta muy buena para calcular este
tipo de áreas esta herramienta es la
función de distribución acumulativa
vamos a denotar la así y es una función
que depende de x nos da el área debajo
de la curva de esta curva digamos que
por aquí anda nuestro punto x justo aquí
nos da el área debajo de la curva hasta
x así que otra forma de pensarlo es que
nos da la probabilidad de que obtengamos
algún valor menor o igual que x así que
el área sería desde menos infinito hasta
x
de nuestra función de probabilidad
y esta es la integral respecto de xy
entonces cuando usamos excel y la
función de distribución normal digamos
es la distribución normal
le tenemos que dar el valor x le damos
la media en la desviación estándar y si
queremos la función acumulativa la
distribución acumulativa en este caso
decimos t de true y en caso de que
queramos la distribución normal que es
esta gráfica le damos false
pulse en mayúsculas así que déjenme
mover esto un poco hacia abajo y sacar
la herramienta de pluma
así que la distribución y la función de
distribución acumulativa está justo aquí
entonces si le ponemos en excel esta es
la función de distribución acumulativa
la misma para esta distribución normal
nada más que aquí estamos acumulando lo
espero que tenga la intuición así que si
queremos saber cuál es la probabilidad
de obtener 20 o menos nos vamos a la
gráfica de esta distribución la
distribución acumulativa de aquí podemos
ver que si vamos a 20 justo nos vamos
casi al a que es la probabilidad la
probabilidad es muy alta de se aproxima
al cien por ciento y eso tiene sentido
porque el área debajo de la curva hasta
20 pues prácticamente es toda no por
ejemplo
cuál es menos la acumulativa la
distribución acumulativa hasta -5
entonces aquí tenemos menos 5 y nos da
justo el 50% y eso es porque menos 5 es
la media y eso nos da justamente que nos
da el 50% verdad ahora si queremos saber
la probabilidad de estar entre menos uno
y uno lo que vamos a hacer es déjenme
regresar a mi herramienta de pluma lo
que lo que tenemos que hacer es calcular
la probabilidad de obtener menos que
menos 1 verdad
así que esto de esta área y después
calculamos la probabilidad de obtener
menos que 1 déjenme hacerlo con otro
color la probabilidad de obtener 1 menos
y restamos el área amarilla a la morada
verdad y obtendremos esta área
justamente que es exactamente lo que
queríamos en realizar y que hicimos en
la hoja de cálculo esto puede ser un
poquito complicado de estar saltando
entre la captura de pantalla de la pluma
y demás así que lo que hicimos fue
evaluar la función en menos 1
perdón primero vamos a evaluarlo en 1
evaluamos en uno la función de
distribución acumulativa y luego
evaluamos en uno en menos uno perdón y
la diferencia entre estos dos nos va a
dar
ese numerito nos dice esencialmente cuál
es la probabilidad de estar entre esos
dos entre menos uno y uno
otra forma de pensarlo es el que nos da
el área del área
debajo de la curva entre menos uno y uno
y realmente los quiero motivarlos a que
empiecen a jugar con excel y todas estas
cosas y los parámetros entonces esto fue
lo que obtuvimos ahora
otra otra pregunta interesante es cuál
es la probabilidad de estar entre las
las líneas de la desviación estándar
digamos esta es la las dos líneas de la
desviación estándar cuál es la
probabilidad de estar entre esas dos
como algunas personas lo piensan cuál es
la probabilidad de estar a lo más una
desviación estándar de distancia de la
media no íbamos a utilizar digamos
en este caso la media es menos 5 y la
desviación estándar es 10 entonces
queremos la probabilidad de entre menos
15 y la media más la desviación estándar
en este caso es 5 verdad entonces
queremos la probabilidad entre menos 15
y 5 que el 68.3 de hecho en este caso es
la probabilidad de caer a lo más en una
desviación estándar de la media
suponiendo que tenemos una distribución
normal y eso pasa para cualquier tipo de
distribución normal y nuevamente este es
el área debajo de esta curva
y la forma en que la obtenemos es con la
distribución de la función de
distribución acumulativa
ok entonces evaluamos en 5 digamos aquí
estamos en el 5
esta es una desviación estándar arriba
de la media digamos esto parece que será
como como un 90% no está arriba del 90 y
digamos si evaluamos en menos 15 más o
menos parece como entre 15 16
quizás 17 vamos a ponerle que es el 18%
verdad pero pero la imagen grande
digamos es a la que hay que restarle la
pequeña verdad entonces
este valor de arriba nos dice la
probabilidad de caer en cinco o menos
muy bien a lo cual hay que restarle la
probabilidad de caer en menos 15 o menos
verdad muy bien
entonces
vamos a subir
entonces cuando cuando tenemos 55 cuando
evaluamos 5 en la función de
distribución acumulativa eso nos da el
área debajo de la curva desde menos
infinito hasta 5 verdad y cuando
evaluamos en menos 15 acá abajo nos dice
la probabilidad de que estemos de este
lado ok entonces si restamos esta área
de la más grande nos quedamos únicamente
con el área debajo de la curva que nos
interesa ahora para entender un poquito
más acerca de esta hoja de cálculo
porque realmente quiero que jueguen con
ella y vean lo que ocurre si hacemos si
cambiamos la distribución
digamos vamos a cambiarlo a la media 5
la gráfica se desplazó hacia la derecha
verdad hasta 5
déjenme cambiarlo ok se desplazó de esta
forma
ahora si cambiamos la desviación
estándar veremos un cambio
cualitativamente muy fuerte digamos si
le ponemos 6 todo parece como una curva
más más apretada y si le ponemos 2 se
vuelve más más apretada más angosta y
quiero que jueguen realmente con estos
parámetros para que tengan una idea
intuitiva de lo que está pasando con la
distribución me hace pensar mucho en
cómo se relaciona con la distribución
binomial que vimos en otro vídeo ahora
para graficar esta curva lo que hice fue
tomar en puntos entre menos 20 y 20 más
o menos y las iba incrementando en
cantidades de 1 digamos así que esto no
es una curva continua simplemente son
puntos gráfica 2 conectados por una
línea después calculé la distancia de
ese punto a la media simplemente tomé
los puntos x menos no en este caso es
menos 5 está calculando esa distancia
así que aquí por ejemplo es menos 20 y
menos 5 son menos 25 solo hice eso hay
aquí en la tercera columna lo que hice
fue calcular básicamente el puntaje z
que es dividir entre sigma que es
cuántas desviaciones estándar caben en
esa distancia verdad por ejemplo en la
primera es 12.5 verdad del lado
izquierdo y luego metí toda esta fórmula
dada por la función de distribución
digamos esté en en menos 20 o en 2 nos
da la altura verdad nos da la altura en
esta curva y luego es bueno eso me da el
valor en la curva pero después dice la
probabilidad de que ocurriera
calculando con la distribución de
función acumulativa verdad de hecho esta
es la probabilidad la función de
distribución acumulativa de que ocurra x
o todos los anteriores o el área debajo
de la curva hasta x verdad aquí por
ejemplo dice 0 pero no es cero sino en
0.00 0 0 1 lo que es ello no está
redondeado hacer
pero bueno entonces la integral debajo
de esta curva tiene que ser 1 porque así
tomar en cuenta todas las posibles
circunstancias y eso debe suceder para
una cantidad muy grande de valores de x
por ejemplo si le damos menos menos
y 1000 nos da el 100% no es el 100% pero
probablemente será como 99.999 99 por
ciento así que de hecho esto lo redondea
para calcular esto simplemente tome la
función de distribución acumulativa del
valor menos 1.000 y se lo reste al de la
función evaluado en 1000 de cualquier
forma espero que ya hayan tenido una
buena sensación una buena intuición de
lo que es la distribución normal les les
les motivó a que tomen esta hoja de
cálculo y empiezan a jugar con ella en
ejercicios posteriores jugaremos también
con esta hoja de cálculo para algunos
modelos digamos si estamos haciendo un
modelo financiero que tiene alguna
distribución normal alrededor de cierto
valor esperado o no sea alguna
distribución de ganancias netas no sé
hay un buen de ejemplos nos vemos en el
próximo vídeo